we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p here is a question i'm
increasingly getting about the
possibility of
mandatory coveted vaccinations take a
listen
hi david this is talia from north
carolina
my question is with the vaccine getting
rolled out
and biden making it one of his
priorities
what do you think will happen with
mandatory vaccines for kids in schools
because i know that
there's many vaccines that the
government has made mandatory for people
to go to school
so do you think biden will have to
decide on that
um so no joe biden's not going to have
to decide on that
the decisions about vaccine requirements
for attending public school
are typically made at the state level
they may be even be made at a more local
level
but typically those are state level
decisions i think we need to be really
careful with our terminology here
a mandatory vaccine is a vaccine that
you are
required to have rather than simply one
that
you can choose to have if you want to
participate in a certain activity or
avail yourself of a certain business
service
or educational institution so it's
really important that we be clear with
the language
the coronavirus vaccine is not going to
be mandatory in the sense that
no government state local federal is
going to force
anyone who doesn't want a vaccine to get
one what we are going to see
and we're already hearing from it is
that everything from
airlines to yes maybe schools
will say if you or your kid want to
travel with us come to a concert live
nation
ticketmaster talking about this maybe
attend our school which is your
choice to do or not to do you would be
required to be vaccinated now
you don't have to be vaccinated you just
might not be able to fly jetblue
maybe delta will allow you i think delta
already said they're going to require
vaccinations this is hypothetical
a a private school could also say at
this school you have to have a
coronavirus vaccine to attend
some private schools have lack serve
rules on vaccination
than public schools some don't so it's
really
important that we not fall into this
idea
of a vaccine made mandatory by a
government
public schools are run by states and
municipalities
they're not going to force a vaccine on
anyone but
they may say if you choose to send your
kid to the school
they must have a vaccine as is already
the case with a number of different
vaccines in different states and
municipalities so
let's take control of what this actually
is which are
requirements for participation as as
they exist
uh in in many different areas across
many different industries
and i do expect that many
businesses because of the risk to their
business
of coronavirus outbreaks will have a
variety of different
uh guidelines that say uh if you want to
fly with us or travel on our train or
whatever employers might say we require
employees to be vaccinated for this or
that
you don't have to work here working here
is optional you can go to a different
employer if you want but
to work here you need this vaccine or
that vaccine
fully expect that that is going to
happen it'll be up to people to decide
whether they want to avail themselves of
a certain school
or of a certain airline or whatever
enough
that they will choose to go and get that
vaccine we have a great bonus show for
you today
we will talk about a federal judge
temporarily blocking joe biden's pause
on deportation
we will talk about how in 2020 airports
people were caught with guns twice as
much in 2020
than in 2019 at american airports
and we will talk about the possibility
of mandatory coveted tests for domestic
air travel
i actually think this is long overdue
and i will explain why on today's bonus
show
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinpakman.com